i saw this video of you trying to teach
your wife a dance move so i'm gonna i'm
gonna play this
oh um
so i'm just gonna i'm just gonna say i
feel like her snap was like a tiny bit
off beat
yeah yeah yeah she tries she tries
you know joyful and look joyful she
looks like she was having a good time
yeah it might not have been in time but
she was having a good time
she was she was like yeah my my whole
existence is just trying to keep her on
the two and the four that's all
i just tried to get her on that
she collapsed on the one and three do
y'all want to y'all sing as well
do y'all do karaoke no we're not we're
well i i
yeah yeah yeah i i do like i love that
you love i'm not
you're not yes i love karaoke yeah yes
i'm not a good singer but i love to sing
and and i do karaoke pick when you 90
since you've been gone that's my
yeah and you know what years later even
on tour i'm like yeah
it feels good just saying like the first
time i sang it
um what's your go-to karaoke probably
fresh prince you know oh god because i
know the words you know yeah
we play that almost every day in here oh
that oh okay i love that
summertime yes that's a good idea that's
the one i meant i meant summertime will
smith
somebody i always call him fresh prince
and his real name is will's
okay yep i'm still here just waiting for
you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help